thank you very much dear secretary
general dear stefano
dear ambassadors
dear heads of representation
the heads of mission ladies and
gentlemen
it is with great pleasure that i am
addressing you today and indeed as
stefano said even if it is also with
great regret
that it is once again from studios and
through screens that we see each other
and i hope we will be able to meet again
in person in spring but indeed i felt it
was important to take this opportunity
to speak to you now at the end of this
year
firstly to thank you
to thank you for your tireless work that
brings to life europe's global
commitment
and secondly of course to make the case
for why that work is so important
at a time when international cooperation
is more tense more tested and more
contested than ever
the pandemic is perhaps the most fitting
place to start
we have all seen
in the last weeks the true scale of the
challenge we still face
against the virus that the world cannot
yet shake off
but if we take a step back
we also see the scale and the speed of
the response
and we see the true value of
international cooperation
remember when we met last year
no vaccine had been approved not a
single dose had been administered
anywhere in the world
today
44 of the world's population has been
fully vaccinated
and a large part of the doses used were
exported from or shared by europe
so let's have a look at the figures
since vaccine production started
while we have delivered around 1 billion
doses of vaccine to the european people
we have in parallel shipped more than
1.4 billion doses of vaccines
from europe to more than 150 countries
we are the only region in the world that
never banned exports
despite and you remember the intense
pressure
and on top
the european union is so far the biggest
donor of covet 19 vaccines in the world
eu member states have shared almost 350
million doses for donation
the large majority around 300 million
doses have been shared via kovacs
and the rest more than 45 million doses
have been delivered by eu member states
through bilateral donations
for instance to our neighbors in the
western balkan
and we will do more
we will step up our effort to support
africa this is very important because
their vaccination is lower
than in other parts of the world
and our overall aim is
to ensure that 70 of the world's
population is vaccinated
by the middle of next year
because we all know
we will only control this pandemic if we
fight it in every corner of the world
these are only a few examples
of team europe delivering support and
solidarity on the ground
i have seen throughout the last year how
crucial eu delegations around the world
have been at coordinating these efforts
and the work that you do on a daily
basis
is really making a difference
and i want to thank you wholeheartedly
for the commitment and the dedication
often in the most trying of
circumstances
i think in particular of the bravery and
the passion of our team in afghanistan
who helped to evacuate so many people
and who continues to work every day
to improve the humanitarian situation on
the ground
i think
together
you have shown the best of europe
and you have demonstrated that
cooperation and partnership
is still the best way to get things done
in a world
recovering too slowly and fracturing too
rapidly
because the global challenges
on the scale we face today
ultimately bind together
the fate and the future of people from
right around the world
just think of the topics from the
pandemic i've just
looked at to climate change or to
question of human rights security or
prosperity you name it
and therefore
i believe
that proving to people
that international cooperation and
democracy
can deliver
is our biggest test with like-minded
partners
this will of course be at the top of the
agenda for the summit for democracy
organized by president biden later this
week
i know that there are some who question
if this discussion
is what the world reads needs right now
or others claim
that
putting democratic progress and values
essential to international engagement
is naive or even an obstacle
to advancing our own strategic interests
for europe
i will always believe that the opposite
argument holds true
and that mainly for two reasons
the first is that democratic progress
is under real threat around the world
including on our own continent
i mean those lucky enough
to have been born and raised in
functioning democracies like me
can sometimes take this point for
granted
but we know we shouldn't
according to freedom house
almost 75 percent of the world's
population are living in countries
where democracy deteriorated last year
and just as worryingly
we have seen the continued rise of
liberal autocracies branding themselves
as democracies
while doing away with checks and
balances
and silencing dissenting opinions
we cannot let the progress we have made
be rolled back
just at the moment when it is most
needed
the rise of extremism and autocracy
can also be a security issue for
countries
and we have seen this ourselves with the
hybrid attack on our borders by the
lukashenko regime in minsk
the instrumentalization of migrants
was cynically orchestrated by a regime
intending to draw attention away
from the repression of its own people
it was led through targeted
disinformation on social media
they offered false promises and
literally lured people to the eu belarus
border putting their lives in danger
but in response
we introduced immediately sanctions in
coordination with the united states
canada and the united kingdom
we worked
spot on with unhcr iom and others
to respond to the humanitarian needs of
the migrants trapped by the lukashenko
regime
and to help them return to their homes
we worked very closely with our member
states to manage the external border of
the european union
we prepared blacklisting of transport
operators
that enable smuggling of people so for
example from airlines
to travel agency and it was interesting
to see that rapidly several airlines and
civil aviation authorities
have immediately stopped unwarranted
travel to belarus
and we reached out to countries of
transit and origin
75 of the migrants trapped at the border
iraqis
and iraq has begun repatriating national
stranded in belarus and i must say we
really welcome
this very good cooperation with iraq
that's in some
we acted immediately we acted united
and working together with partners is
effective and it sends a very clear
signal
that we stand with lithuania latvia and
poland
and that we will continue to stand up to
those who instrumentalize the hopes and
the lives of people
the ambassadors
in this context we must also speak about
the russian military movements
and their massive buildup along
ukraine's eastern border
i want to underline once more
the eu's full and unwavering support for
ukraine
in the face of this aggression
against its territorial integrity and
sovereignty
we also see
the blatant attempt
to intimidate moldova's reformist
government
by manipulating our supplies in a time
of high energy prices
we must protect our societies and
democracies from this kind of cynical
geopolitical power play
and the european union will respond
appropriately to any further aggressions
including breaches of international law
and any other malicious actions
taken against us or our neighbors
including ukraine
this response will take the form of
robust scaling up and expansion
of existing sanctions regimes
and on top of that we are ready to take
additional restrictive measures
and of course we will do so in
coordination
with our like-minded partners
now to be very clear
we would rather engage constructively
with moscow
but it depends on them
and currently
it is russia's deliberate choices and
aggressive actions
that continue to destabilize security in
europe
the second reason why europe must always
promote democracy
is that
democratic progress
can easily spread and we have seen this
here in europe on many occasions in the
last 50 years
it was only in 1974
that the so-called third wave of
democracy started in portugal and
reached spain
and after the fall of the soviet union
we saw the remarkable progress
which brought so many countries from out
in the cold
into the heart of our european union
and this has shown us the power
that democracy has
to give people hope
that positive change is possible
but we also know that this momentum
works both ways
so autocracies can rise just as fast
and can infect others
and this risk is particularly acute
in an age of disinformation
when it takes little effort
to reach with fake news a large audience
can be used as a weapon to shape public
perceptions
and mislead people into believing that
democracy does not work for them
and this shows the importance of working
together on the issues which directly
affect the way
democracy works
take for example
the digital transition
it brings about so many opportunities
for our economies our industries and of
course for our societies
and digital technologies are key
to the way
we have been able to manage the impact
of the pandemic and to tackle some of
humanity's greatest challenges like for
example climate change
so this is why we are heavily investing
in the digital as part of our recovery
plan
through next generation eu
but we are also aware that tech has
posed new challenges
which no democracy has yet really found
a way to manage
we now have large tech companies
who have the power to control decisions
right across society
they are able to collect huge amounts of
data
from people's activities online
to target what they see
and to influence how they act
and if this is left unchecked
democracy will not change with a big
bank
but rather with a barely visible but
far-reaching shift
currently just four big companies
control the world's demand for cloud
services
they have the ability
to control the data
which will run our economies and our
cities in the very near future
and this makes a small group of
companies
major geopolitical players
with influence over every part of our
society
the good news is
that we have seen a broad convergence of
views among democracies
on the challenge this poses to all of us
but we have also seen a huge divergence
of approach in terms of how to manage
this risk
for europe
we take the position
that if you want to be a tech leader
and we do
then you must be a leader in tech
regulation too
and this is why we have proposed the new
digital services act
and the digital markets act
both put clear requirements
on online platforms
to accept responsibility for the way
in which they distribute promote and
remove
content it will ensure more transparency
on how algorithms work
and why we are targeted with certain ads
or content
it will open up fair competition for
example by ensuring that search engines
do not get an unfair advantage
so
just as we did with the gdpr
europe is ready to take the lead to
shape the global standards and rules
in line with our human-centric and
democratic values
and i'm proud of that leadership
i'm proud
that europe will always work with
like-minded partners to achieve those
goals
this is why we have also started work on
the eu us trade and technology council
and it is why we want to develop close
alliances on tech and digital standards
with other partners
we need this cooperation to shape the
digital world
and to ensure that our values drive the
way
new technologies are developed and
deployed
the ambassadors
this is just one example of how
democracy offers
i think the best model
to tackle the most pressing challenges
and i say that because
democracies
put people first
they aim to deliver on the expectations
of society
in a way that is peaceful
and not at the expense of others
of course democracy
including ours
is not perfect by design or in reality
but the nature
of those imperfections
is what makes it stand out from
autocracy
because it allows base for debate and
criticism
and it allows space for new ideas to
improve the way it works
and that's why i look very much forward
to code sharing one of the two leaders
panels at this week's democracy summit
i am deeply convinced
that we must work together to show
that democracy can deliver for people
where it counts the most
and there is nothing
that counts more than when it comes to
our fight against climate change and
nature loss
this is the defining challenge of our
generation
and it will dominate politics and
geopolitics
for decades to come
this is why we created the european
green deal
since we last met
europe has gone further and faster than
ever before
we adopted our first climate law
and became the first major economy to
put forward concrete measures
to meet our reduction target
of emissions by 2030.
of course the european green deal does
not work in isolation
it will have an impact on our partners
whether it be through the carbon border
adjustment mechanism
or our efforts to curb global
deforestation for example
so our role is
to explain how we will support our
partners
through these transition
and to go together down this same path
now
there are some that say we should not be
so ambitious
given that we only account for around
eight percent of global emissions
that's true
but we are also the third largest
economy
our famous single market
and if we are able to show that it can
be done
to reconcile
our climate
with the economy
to deliver on growth through the green
transformation
if we are able to prove that it is
possible
through innovation and with a just
transition
then nothing is more convincing
also in view of the devastating damage
that climate change brings along
so there is an alternative
this is a generational task without any
question
and it will involve all of us playing
our role
and this was exactly the message i took
to cop 26
when we announced
a further increase of our contribution
for climate finance
and it is why we were pleased to join
forces for example with others
on a partnership with south africa
to support their shift away from coal
and towards a low emission economy
so these are examples that show what can
be achieved
but we will have to work hard at it
without any question
because the climate change
and the path to net zero
has of course the potential to intensify
competition and friction between major
powers
those who move first
and move fastest
will have the biggest advantage
and those who rely on fossil fuels as a
geopolitical tool
will look to slow it down
and make markets more volatile
and this only reinforces the need for us
to work together with our partners to
accelerate the twin transition around
the world
and this was exactly the thinking behind
the global gateway
as many of you know
the need for global infrastructure is
massive
and it is urgent
so
this investments we know that holds the
key force countries around the world
to improve the lives of their citizens
and to meet the twin transitions
to create jobs in local communities
and to provide better and more equal
access to essential services
whether it is speaking of health care
or education
from energy to transport
or
digital technologies
and this investment is equally important
to tackling the most complex global
challenges we faced
just as the urgency grows
so does the investment deficit
and now comes the point
this leaves
too many countries
with limited options to choose from
they want to invest
but the options are questionable
it can lead to taking unsustainable
offers to secure investment
which can leave a heavy mark on a
country's finances
or on the rights of local communities
for years to come
the dependencies this can create
directly affects the autonomy of those
countries
so
there is space
and there is huge demand
for a positive
a sustainable and a values-driven offer
an offer which puts standards
transparency
and partnership first
and global gateway is europe's offer
it will aim to unlock 300 billion euro
for investment right around the world
to speed up the global twin transition
it is about designing projects that
deliver lasting social and economic
benefits for local communities
in a way that also benefits europe and
our own strategic interests around the
world
so this is not just about developing
cloud and data infrastructure or
building renewable energy capacity it's
also about that
but it is also about ensuring that
people can make the most of the benefits
this can bring
so the ambassadors
when we look at today's world
we see just how many
groundbreaking inventions we have
witnessed in the last years from for
example 5g or artificial intelligence
to solar power clean transport smart
grid technologies you name it
this has improved the way we do things
across europe
and in most major economies
but if we look at the world
the benefits
of these innovations are not felt by a
large proportion of the global
population
so i believe
that the greatest innovations of the
21st century will be those
which ensure that new innovations
can be used and benefited by all
and this will not only require
investment and infrastructure
and stronger supply chains
but also in people in skills in
knowledge
and in the capacity to ensure that they
can be used and operated
and this is where i believe europe and
global gateway have a competitive
advantage
thanks to our world-class researchers
industry and public and private
innovation capacity
and
thanks to your role
on the ground
this will be absolutely central to
global gateway's ability to bring all of
these elements together
we need you to work with our partners
to really identify investment needs and
concrete projects
and to work with member states embassies
to ensure we take a team europe approach
to this fantastic challenge
the ambassador's
wizard is on health infrastructure
development
climate change or digitalization all
topics
i was briefly touching
the world needs to work together to get
things done
there have been many successes in the
last year
by the way not at least the historic
agreement signed by around about 130
countries to make the global tax system
fairer
but we should also not shy away from
where there have also been difficult
moments for global cooperation
which have a profound impact on our
union
this only reinforces the need for europe
to focus on making itself stronger
both to be a better partner but also to
be able to better protect our own
interests and values
this is why we have stepped up our own
work to give ourselves the instruments
to do that
we will soon present a new tool
to dissuade others from using coercion
tactics against us
this tool will equip us with the
necessity to take trade investment or
other restrictive measures
towards those putting undue pressure on
us
we are also strengthening our
partnership with nato on security and
defense
i recently traveled to the baltics with
secretary general jens stoltenberg
and we are working closely on an eu nato
joint declaration
but it is not a new assessment
that europe can and clearly should also
be able and willing to do more on its
own
this will help us provide stability in
our own region and beyond
to better prepare for new threats
and to ensure that we make the most of
our unique combination of strength when
we need to act
so this will be a core theme of our work
in the year ahead
and it shows that europe needs to draw
on its own strength and work closely
with our allies and partners all across
the world
so we will continue to work on all our
partnerships even the most challenging
or complex ones
because
i think we must never see diplomacy
as an endorsement of the other side
but rather as a way to get things done
and to protect our own interests
this is the skill
which hiv p joseph burrell has in
abundance
and i want to thank him
for his leadership and unwavering
support over the last
year and i want to thank all of you
for doing the same
i very much look forward to seeing you
soon hopefully in person
and now i wish you a peaceful and a
successful end of the year
stay healthy